ça fait donc lourdement endetté je vous
le disais est ce nouveau contrat entre
l'entreprise et d'état qui doit être
connus lundi fait peur aux cheminots y
voient une remise en cause de leurs
conditions de travail
davantage acquis également et de la
nature même du service public des
chemins de fer français pascal golomer
luc blachon un chiffre un seul pour
résumer l'urgence des décisions à
prendre
la sncf a accumulé jusqu'à aujourd'hui
175 milliards de francs de dette en
remboursant uniquement les intérêts de
cette dette
l affiche du coup un déficit de 12
milliards de francs cette année qui
viennent s'ajouter à la dette évidemment
un cercle vicieux qu'il faut casser
c'est tout l'objet des négociations
entre l'état et la sncf
ce contrat va être un contrat d'
d'efforts partagés comme on dit c'est à
dire que l'entreprise va s'engager à des
améliorations des progrès de
l'amélioration de sa qualité vue voilée
par les clients et aussi du côté de
l'état l'état va nous encourager nous
aider à cette évolution qui compris
financièrement sur un certain nombre de
points
l'état qui fera d'abord un chèque tout
de suite pour alléger la dette 25 à 30
milliards de francs dit on mais rien
n'est encore officiel pour le reste tout
dépendra de l'amélioration des résultats
et donc des efforts que fera la sncf
au programme la poursuite des
suppressions d'emplois cinq mille par an
actuellement
le chiffre pourrait s'accroître une
moindre augmentation des salaires aussi
enfin une nouvelle organisation du
travail une plus grande polyvalence des
agents
à cela s'ajoute le transfert vers les
régions de la gestion des petites ling
ling souvent déficitaires vous pourrez
être transféré sur autocar ou fermer
définitivement
autant de sujets d'inquiétude pour les
cheminots c'est une partie difficile qui
se joue la direction et le gouvernement
le savent eux qui redoute plus que tout
un long conflit social comme celui de
1986 des cheminots avait-elle en fait
grève pendant 22 jours